we have seen the very best in the
American people and we have seen the
worst the best the best doctors the best
nurses the best medical professionals
working round the clock putting
themselves in harm's way we have the
best scientists medical researchers
making historic strides in finding
treatment options faster than ever
before in history we are now all blessed
to live in a country to have so many
gifted and talented people working this
hard members of the US military they are
now assisting States nationwide the best
of the best and breaking today the
president just issued an executive order
bringing reserve forces back online as
active duty personnel the president also
invoked the defense production act
mandating the general motors produced
thousands of new ventilators why they
were acting too slow look at your screen
GM now joins all of these other great
companies you can see that on your
screen that move heaven and earth to
produce the mass the ventilators the
medical equipment the emergency supplies
and get them delivered all these
life-saving products all over the
country where and when needed and just
today airplane giant Boeing announced
that it would also be producing
much-needed face shields these
corporations they do deserve a lot of
credit so does the president so does his
task force they have led from the day
one yeah when they were being called
xenophobic and racist and hysterical and
fear mongers from public-private
partnerships to drive up testing sites
soon to be home testing sites the travel
ban the paradigm shift how we will deal
with future pandemics is now literally
being rewritten and unfolding right
before your eyes this is now history in
the making now sadly there are some
people I'm glad it's a minority who are
so afflicted with their rage hatred and
Trump derangement syndrome they won't
give him credit for one thing last night
I touched on the incessant never-ending
constant complaining and frankly lack of
accountability of that guy New York
Governor Andrew Cuomo his state is the
epicenter of the corona virus in the
United States they are facing a real
crisis New Yorkers need and deserve
help and the president has rightly
directed the full complete support of
the federal government and precedented
assistance has been given and will be
given as promised billions of dollars in
federal funding Chuck Schumer said at
least out of this bill forty billion
dollars that was signed into law will go
to New York on top of that that US Navy
hospital ship it will be leaving
tomorrow it will be in New York Harbor
on Monday for temporary hospitals have
been are being erected by the Army Corps
of Engineers Donald Trump is making that
happen and look at your screen another
1000 bed hospital set up by FEMA look at
that that's at the Javits Center in
Manhattan in New York to prepare for
potential overcrowding that's five
separate hospitals the president has
secured for Cuomo the state of New York
the city of New York President also sent
the National Guard to help with state to
help the state with logistics and he
said yep more than 4,000 ventilators
alone this week everything that New York
will need Cuomo has requested the
president has delivered but you know I
watch day after day and he says that he
talks with such great authority you know
these politicians all talk no action
that's what we're getting from Cuomo
sounds great sounds authoritative sounds
wonderful came on my radio show for 40
minutes yeah we'll all work together
today he had nothing but more whining
bitching and complaining it's getting
pathetic Andrew what are you doing and
why didn't you prepare better we'll
examine this take a look were there
ventilators found in a storage facility
or something that the president's is
claiming that there were ventilators
found that they need to be distributed
is there any
so that that is that is incorrect and
grossly uninformed the the point is we
have ventilators in a stockpile and we
didn't send them to the hospitals yeah
of course we didn't that's the whole
point the hospitals don't need them yet
oh they don't they don't need them yet
it's a nice Hospital behind you
thank Donald Trump maybe one so I'll
just say thank you mr. president thank
you to the American people they're
paying that bill now he even admits I
don't currently have a ventilator
shortage in New York we need 40,000 okay
if you need 40,000 we'll get your 40,000
you're not even using the money the
4,000 you got this week as circumstances
change the president has pledged to
everybody he will continue to move
heaven and earth to get New York and
every other state any ventilators any
medical equipment they need it's not
exactly been the simplest endeavor nice
Hospital behind you
oh the country paid for that governor
the country and the country does and now
have the right to get answers from you
both the governor in New York and the
mayor of New York City New York is an
international state and it's an
international City New York City people
from all over the globe come right here
we know last year that the state of New
York they spent over 170 billion dollars
I know I live here I pay a fortune in
taxes as does everybody else the city of
New York they spent another 90 billion
dollars so why didn't they have the
emergency supplies at all they seem to
have little or none zero preparation
what part of being the number one terror
target in the country did they not seem
to understand because you got millions
of people highly concentrated in a very
small area how is it possible you were
not prepared for emergencies like
pandemics close proximity millions of
people yeah you would be most likely to
have the most difficulty Governor Cuomo
you are now in your third four-year term
as governor there's no excuses
sit in there lecturer I need 40,000 of
this and 60,000 of that really why
didn't you do your job and allocate the
emergency dollars for moments
predictably like this weird New York's
the number one target in the entire
United States for terrorism
now Andrew Cuomo we have looked at how
you have spent money in New York look at
this a whopping 750 million dollars for
a solar panel factory by the way where
is it now close down 90 million for a
light bulb factory or company in
California what's that whatever happened
to that Andrew or the 600 million you
spent on a computer chip factory that
sits empty millions spent for Oh
brand-new I Love New York sides governor
I have a question for you how many
ventilators how many gowns how many
masts how many gloves how many
respirators how many generators how much
fuel could you have stored and have
purchased which is some of that money
and yet every day he goes out there
needs us I need the sea needs that's not
going fast enough
I need 40,000 ventilators you're not
using the 4,000 you have and he sits
there lecturing the president and the
task force they're moving heaven and
earth rightly so for the city and for
the state how about saying thank you to
the American people they're making that
happen for you the president his task
force they're making that all happen for
you great photo-op in the hospital they
built for you and don't forget according
to a former New York State lieutenant
governor in 2015
remember yeah Wow even the liberal media
mob reported this Cuomo was warned that
his state would need additional
ventilators to manage any future
pandemics he chose not to buy them I
guess he needed the money for the solar
stuff so you got Cuomo comrade de Blasio
whining bitching complaining every
single day they take no responsibility
for their failure to prepare and wasting
all the waste fraud and abuse on their
watch governor mayor maybe it's time
you'd be grateful to the federal
assistance that you will rightly
continue to receive as it pours into the
state of New York you have any problems
with the bill passed only three point
five billion no you're you're Senator
Chuck Schumer says over forty billion
the president has been delivering on his
promises to you and Cuomo and de Blasio
well you need to now start doing the
same which brings us to even a lower
point Hillary Clinton Hillary once again
proving she is a national disgrace
bitter twice failed presidential
candidate now seemingly cheering for the
virus on Twitter tweeting out headline
us now leads the world in coronavirus
cases I guess she probably believes the
Chinese propaganda along with a message
quote he did promise America first
that's a new low even for her hey
Hillary people are sick and people are
dying and thank God that vindictive
angry attention C seeker is not
president because she lost you think she
would have enacted the travel ban do you
think that would have happened with
Hillary quarantine think that would have
happened with Hillary I think she would
have met that one decision saving tens
of thousands of Americans from crack
contracting this disease I doubt it
she would have called it xenophobic
racist you know hysteria Hillary Clinton
in a crisis well we have some examples
of that we all remember how well she
handled Benghazi and let's not forget
she served in the obama-biden
administration yep 2009-2010 in Joe's
words the N one H one pandemic when the
federal stockpile of n95 masks were
totally depleted by Obama and Biden
guess what even the Washington Post
points out they never replace them that
put that set everybody back in this case